[Music]
hold the fudge you mean to tell me that
nobody snapped up those bad boys today's
the day like every other day i'll be
back for those
oh this is close
this is the greatest cup of coffee of
all time i want to write a song about it
i want to dance to that song my body i
love my life it's about finding a lane
and just staying in it that's why they
call them comfort zones they're so damn
comfortable
mondays am i right joe you said it guy
wow life in the big city ain't nothing
like it
i mean when you put it on there
[Music]
don't have a good day have a great day
that's a new one
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
that's the dream girl buddy
he's just resting
and pleases that man is dead he's so
sleepy
i'm just gonna put your gun down
right here
for when you wake
okay
yeah
dad
where you going
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
excuse me
do you see this
a quarterly reports on my desk by friday
uh
[Music]
feel brand new
[Music]
seriously man i'm just being honest i
think the bunny suit is just a little
much
excuse me
right
rabbit okay my fault
hey four-year-old virgin get over here
let's go uh-huh captain khakis come here
go let's go come on bud closer there he
is blue shirt guy
blue shirt
yes hello officer
rabbit nice skin thank you
that's sweet
how did you get it well uh
mostly genetics i think i'm pretty lucky
i have i have naturally dewy skin listen
up neutrogena you know you can't go
around looking like that the rules are
clear and another thing you can't hack
the npc avatars no sir it screws up the
mission loads and it makes the game look
bad horrible
i got like five percent of that lose the
skin
to get rid of my skin take it off man
just take it off what are you doing what
seriously the whole thing the face the
outfit everything ditch it if you don't
we're gonna kill you and we're gonna
keep killing you still watch until we do
find out who you are and then we're
gonna ban you for life no no okay i i
want to comply i just find the order of
those threats very somebody's about to
get them off
[Music]
wow
you should definitely go
[Music]
is that a glock in your pocket no what
it's two clocks
[Music]
[Music]
i don't suppose this thing can fly
dude we're still working on him i worked
on him myself he's perfect dropping dude
now
who are you
catchphrase catchphrase well that don't
think went up yet well the catchphrase
the catchphrase is a pretty cool
catchphrase
am i a role model
i don't know i mean i do know that you
hear about actors complaining about how
hard their movie workouts are
and i'll tell you i don't have time for
that i've been at this one week
and i gotta tell you
it's coming in nicely
[Music]
i start every day with a protein bomb
it's made exclusively of human muscle
it's completely organic and illegal
acting is
mind over matter
and judgment
and common sense
sure i don't fit into the deadpool suit
anymore
but life is about growth
hormones
[Music]
well i actually fathered our youngest
daughter when i was this muscular
the child was born
full grown
and wearing shoes
which was
weird for blake
[Music]
who is this i don't know i mean he's
just like you but way better with the
movement i think he's gonna
hit you he punches so hard but yeah his
hands are so soft
daddy needs to express some rage
[Music]
well hello there and what's up reaction
faction it's deadpool don't forget to
smash that subscribe button and follow
me on patreon last week you all really
liked my cruella trailer reaction video
where are the [ __ ] dogs so this week
i'll be reacting to a trailer for a
movie which i honestly thought came out
like a year ago free guy
apparently it's this august we also have
a guest reactor this week
korg who was not my first choice but
apparently everyone else was too busy
over on disney plus
say hello korg hello made of rocks thank
you for having me paul sorry you're dead
jesus christ
let's take a look
my name is guy oh he's named guy like
the movie's title that's pretty clever
it
i've got a best friend this is the
greatest cup of coffee of all time
mondays am i right joe you said it guys
let's just pause for a second let
everyone comment first or this trailer
gives away too much or ryan reynolds is
just me which is super insulting by the
way
all done and i work at the bank
everybody
i thought i had everything i needed
but then i met her oh
jody comer god i love her so much oh i
hope they don't fridge her what's
fridging uh well it's the practice of
killing off or hurting a female
character in order to motivate or
torture the main character also known as
deadpool 2. thank you for asking ah we
call that bridging
everybody down on the ground
everybody accept you
there's something inside you guys we
expected you to just fall
situation more than that put these on
okay
fine oh my god
[Music]
what are these strict glasses or
something it's about your glasses the
glass trigger this world it's a video
game you're not real
please stop
i'm the guy responsible for this world
any thoughts on our villain cork uh
looks like he's got four arms and the
two lower ones have got gloves on i like
him
you have a disney plush show don't you
face
oh god
trademark infringement doesn't mean that
nothing you do matters i am sitting here
with my best friend trying to help him
get through a tough time now that's not
real i don't know what it is
i know this world
look at him go that little blue shirt
oh his face is so punchable next guy i'm
gonna be the great guy
well enjoy your lifetime supply of
virginity
this whole good guy routine is ruining
the game
him let's take a whitey t he seems quite
nice actually
a rabbit
maybe this is the live-action thumper we
all haven't been waiting for
[Music]
[Applause]
love it i can't die
clean that's gonna
[Music]
okay this looks fun in a
in a last days of fox fire sale kind of
way not sure if it was worth diverting
canadian cumberbatch's little mind away
from my next movie or you know what i'm
gonna give it uh i'll give it four out
of five avocados cork
i was raised by avocados oh my god just
kill me now
[Music]
any uh
any tips on uh getting into the mcu
there cork uh have a dream
uh chase it
lose that dream just sabotage all sorts
of happiness
in pursuit of that dream climb up to the
peaks of that mountain and when you get
to the top land at the bottom and
realize you're never going to achieve
that dream and at that point
check your emails maybe you'll get
something from your agent saying marvel
wants to talk
yeah i prefer dark world
half a [ __ ] penny of you for this
[Music]